you've been producing music for so long
and producing hits for other people that
it's got to feel nice when people
recognize you as the lead singer you
know what I mean yeah it's incredibly
humbling isn't it it's like it's like
it's like a beautiful thing because I
think you're like one of those generous
people who's always produced other
people's music you've always given hits
to other people you write music for
other people and I would think it's
difficult to watch them be the household
name while you were kind of in the
background I never seen it like that
ever in fact um when the executives over
at
Colombia um Rob Stringer the chairman
and Ashley Newton the uh president there
who had actually sign me 13 years ago at
a different label called virgin yeah
during The Wonder Years they were the
ones that said you know um you know you
you've just featured on this song with
da Punk is called Get Lucky
and uh we know you don't want to make a
solo record so we'd like to be the first
to change your mind so for me in my mind
it was like okay cool because they had
the coolest label in the world they had
everybody from Adele and da Punk that
they had recently signed hence the
conversation yeah and they would always
say to me you know but you got to be
selfish you have to you know start
keeping things for
yourself and that's because I think they
that was largely in part to the fact
that they they knew that I didn't see it
that way I didn't see it like well okay
cool I'm going to give you this and
you're going to have this great time and
here am I going to be stuck with
whatever instead i' I've always looked
at it like you know I wanted to be an
artist like in my early
early early 20s in the very beginning
but that was like stomped out by just
like you know just kind of crushed by a
bunch of no no NOS you're weird and left
and you wear weird things and we'll just
stick to the things that you write and
produce for other people and I kind of
got accustomed to that and I started to
enjoy writing through people and and uh
producing for people and you know
because they I found people to have like
these really interesting foreign
energies that would inspire me and take
me to places that I probably wouldn't go
on my
own